what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to shoot i'm going to be reacting to
dating tips for women of all ages um by
matthew hussey before i start do not
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos um also copper sweatshirt they're
only selling for four more days the
material is literally so soft it is my
favorite sweatshirt i have ever owned in
my life
it literally goes with anything so yeah
buy it please
okay it's going to be interesting to see
if i agree with this dating tips i was
on tv recently when a woman in her 50s
came to me and she said i've been
divorced for four years since then i've
been dating on tinder i've been on
online dating sites i've been
trying to be proactive in my life life
i've been dating she said but you know
it seems like so many of the men i'm
meeting are either guys who are younger
and they're attracted to the older woman
but that's not necessarily going to last
or they're my own age or older who are
looking for the the 25 year old or the
30 year old who's way beneath their age
group and having some sort of midlife
crisis now the thing i loved about this
woman
that's
men tend to like younger women usually
is that she said to me it's not that i
don't believe that the guys are out
there who are in the right age group for
me and have been through that mid-life
crisis and are looking for someone now
that they can actually relate to and
have a real relationship with she said i
know they're out there she said but
they're so hard to find and she said i
have a 15 year old son and that takes up
a lot of my time and i also i'm an
entrepreneur she works with people in
social media so she said so that takes
up my time as well she said so there's
limited time and i really understand
this person or at least i can understand
how difficult it must be for this person
to think about going out there and
finding someone as she put it to spend
the next 40 years with you know she saw
herself as young and she said i've got a
lot of years left in my life i want to
find someone to spend it with but how am
i going to find that guy that i really
want to spend the rest of my life with
and spent wants to spend the rest of his
life with me
firstly every single one of us has
things that we want to do in our lives
before we die we have this kind of life
list right you're young at your age
you're in your 50s you're young you've
got many many years why are we lying
you are not young
like
how old do people live to
matthew let's just okay
average
age um of
trying to think of
death oh god
u.s
uh 76
for men so i'm just gonna assume it's
like
80 for women
so
it's like 30 that's not young yeah out
of the things that you still want to do
which of those could you bring forward
and do today
and the reason i say that is because
it's when we're out there doing things
that we have the opportunity to be
exposed to a different type of person
than we're normally meeting so yes you
can be on online dating sites and that's
fine and and i applaud that and i think
that's a great vehicle but that doesn't
mean it has to be your only vehicle you
could still be out there meeting a
different type of man that you then
you're meeting right now by doing some
of the things that you want to do anyway
you know have you always wanted to be
part of a a really interesting peer
group i think that's good advice
actually like do the things you're
interested in i i think that's good
advice um if i was that age i would
probably just hire a matchmaker to be
honest people intellectually that read
certain books is there a book club you
can go and join is there a travelling
group you can be a part of that actually
travels around and goes to see places
together have you always wanted to be a
better runner and you said you've always
said to yourself you know what i've
always hated running but i really have
wanted to be good at it my whole life i
want to join a running group what is it
right now that you can be a part of
that you want to do at some point in
your life but you've been putting off
those things even if you don't meet the
right guy when you're there you won't
regret doing because they're things you
wanted they were on your life list
anyway that's good advice i think from
men and women that's good at times so
i'd encourage you to go and do those i
know that you don't have time to go and
take up 50 new things when you've got a
son and when you've got things going on
in your life when you're working hard to
pay the bills i know you don't have time
for all of that but you do have time for
the things you wanted to do in your life
anyway and those are the things you need
to start bringing forward because
they'll bring you into contact with new
people the second piece of advice is to
socialize the activities that you're
already doing if right now you go to the
gym and you work out with your
headphones in and you're on your own in
your solitary workout maybe you need to
join a class where you're doing the same
thing or something similar right a
little bit compromised never hurt
anybody but you're doing similar things
in a group of people there's guys there
or maybe it's an all-women class it
doesn't matter if you have new single
friends those can be just as helpful as
meeting a hot guy in your class because
they're going to be the ones banging on
your door saying let's go out next week
so meeting new people in ways that you
would normally be spending time on your
own get creative on doing the most
social version of whatever you do in
your life anyway people
i like this advice people talk a lot of
[ __ ] about matthew
hussy especially in the red pill
but
uh right here i don't disagree with not
the only thing i disagree with is 50 is
not young like get out of here i often
think that meeting the right guy is
something that has to take away from
everything else in your life like
they're mutually exclusive goals i'm
either doing all of the things i
actually want to do in my life or i'm
out there doing a bunch of [ __ ] i don't
want to do to meet the right guy doesn't
have to be that way my view on it is
this spend your life
actively doing the things that you
really want to do
but if you're looking to meet someone do
the most sociable version of the things
you're going to do anyway
and start ticking off some of the things
you should say hire a
matchmaker think at that age that's
kevin samuels says that a lot and i i
think it's good advice because
at that age so many of the people you're
trying to date are married so it's just
going to be hard to find them even if
you're going out all the time
that are on your life list
that you know maybe you were saying
yourself you're going to do in five
years or 10 years start doing some of
them today because if they get you out
there and get you meeting people they're
going to be killing two birds with one
stone you're living your life the way
you always wanted to live it and you're
bringing yourself into contact with new
and interesting people this is an
exciting time in your life you don't
give in to the excuses that everyone
feeds you instead go out there and live
the life you want to live and get
proactive about meeting the type of men
you want to meet so i love that you're
here watching i love that you're the
proactive type of woman that actually
wants to do something in her love life
whatever rage you're at i know you
wouldn't who me
me you wouldn't be watching this right
now if you weren't that type of oh yeah
and if you want more what a salesman
he's like buttering up his clients
you watch me
well you're a proactive won't like
compliment compliment compliment thank
you matthew help with this because i
come here every week on youtube and give
you lots of different ideas but if you
want a specific approach to getting out
there and talking to guys starting to
build real relationships with new types
of guys
go here i have programs for this we'll
link it up right here scripts what are
his scripts
um
that was an interesting video that
actually wasn't so bad i've heard such
horrible things about matthew hussey
from the red pill community i was
expecting it to be worse
and i actually thought that was pretty
good advice but let me know in the
comments what you guys think don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell buy my
sweatshirts please i'll talk to you guys
next time